طبعا يوم بعد يوم تزداد تكهنات حول الهجوم
المضاد الواسع الذي تحضر له القوات
الاوكرانيه منذ اشهر من اجل صد القوات
الروسيه ومن اجل طردها ايضا من المناطق
شرقيه البلاد وفيما اكدت روسيا اليوم بدات
بالفعل هذا الهجوم الواسع على منطقه
طبعا يعم السكون الجانب الاوكراني بل ان
الجيش الاوكراني جدد مطالبته بالتزام
الصمت فيما يتعلق بتنفيذ هذا الهجوم الذي
طال انتظاره وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه قالت
ان الخطط تحب الصمت وانها لن تعلم ولن
تعلن عن بدء هذا الهجوم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات